this process has been so crazy
with all eyes on nevada voters here in
las vegas
are restless i'm pretty sure people
haven't slept for the last 48 hours i
don't understand why
why it's taking so long to count all the
ballots ballots were cast on tuesday
which means their job is done but
bunnies say
they're ready for the election to end i
think nevada is definitely really
divided and you can really feel that
here
it feels like one you know for every one
friend that's voting for trump there's
another friend voting for biden so it
really is that swing state
presidential picks are painting our
country's climate
and those we spoke with urge others to
trust the political process
even if it does take a little longer
there's so many great volunteers out
there right now they're just
they just care about democracy and they
want it to be fair
um so i think it's not the time to
listen to
you know all the rhetoric going around
saying that
it's a faulty process no matter which
way this goes
they said we can only keep looking
forward there's nothing you can do about
it at this point if you voted you know
you made a difference
and we'll see what happens and vow to
work together
regardless of what the future holds if
any change is going to happen it's not
going to be based on who's sitting in
the white house it's going to be based
on us
sasha loftis 8 news now